Well, I've been requested to do
some videos on concativity and
maxima and minimum points and
inflection points, and all the
like that you normally see in
your first semester of
a calculus course.
So, I thought I would
start doing them.
But before we kind of go into
the actual problems that you
might see in your book, I just
want to give you a
broad intuition.
Because in calculus class,
people-- there are all these
rules, when, you know, the
second derivative is positive,
you're concave this way.
When the second derivative
is negative, you're
concave this way.
And people memorize the rules,
and they take the tests, and if
they memorize it correctly
they do well on the tests.
And then they forget it.
Maybe they memorize it again by
the time of the final exam.
But by the time they are
30 years old, they will
have forgotten it.
And that, frankly, is useless.
Unless your whole goal
is just to pass exams.
So I want to give
you some intuition.
And hopefully, you will never
forget this intuition.
So when you're first learning
calculus there's much more
to functions than what I'm
going to do in this video.
But there's kind of 3 types of
interesting points on most of
the curves we'll talk about.
So let's say, let
me draw a curve.
Let's say the curve looks
something like this.
You know, if this is the
x-axis-- that's too thick--
that's the y-axis.
The curve could look
something like this.
I don't know.
Let me see.
It could look like this.
And so on.
And if you have a curve like
this-- and you'll see all sorts
of curves when you do your
calculus, because you have
multiple degree polynomials, et
cetera-- what are the
interesting points?
Well, the interesting
points tend to be when
the slope is equal to 0.
So, in this, where does
the slope equal 0?
What are the interesting
points here?
Let me make sure I'm
using the right tool.
Right there the
slope is 0, right?
Because if you were to take the
tangent right there, it would
look something like that.
Right there the slope is 0, as
well, because if you took the
tangent it would look
something like that.
And then right there, as
well, the slope is 0.
And the line, it really
isn't a tangent.
It crosses the graph.
But as we could see, the graph
kind of flattens out there.
So these are the three points
that you tend to deal with in
your first semester calculus
class when you're graphing
and looking for extrema.
And this is called a maximum.
And in this case,
it's a local maxima.
If, you know, if this was the
highest point for the entire
function, it would be
a global maximum.
This is a local minima.
And if it was, you know, if it
was the lowest point of the
entire graph-- which is the way
I drew it-- maybe this graph
keeps going up like that, and
keeps going up like this.
So this would be the
global minimum point.
And then this is called an
inflection point, because it's
neither a maximum, minimum, but
you kind of see that the
graph kind of inflects.
So let's study them a little
bit more and see if we can get
a little intuition on what
happens to the graph, the first
derivative, and the second
derivative, at each
of these points.
Let's start with a maximum
point, because maybe that's--
well, let's start with a
minimum point, because that's
what we see the most.
You know, when we used to study
y equals x squared, or regular
parabolas, that was the
most common thing we saw.
And then of course, if we have
a negative of a parabola,
it becomes like that.
But anyway, let's study a
minimum point where the
graph is concave upward.
Let's say we have a
point like this.
So that's the graph
of the function.
I don't know what that
is, that's f of x.
So what is happening to
the slope as we go from--
roughly-- from here to there?
Well, let's try a few points
and see if we can, by drawing
the tangent lines, we get
intuition for the slope.
So let's see, if I pick this
point, just randomly, the slope
looks something like that.
I'm trying to do a tangent.
If I take this point-- I'm just
moving to the right a little
bit, I'm just increasing my
x value-- the slope will
look something like that.
So it's negative here, but
if you look here, the
slope is less negative.
The slope is less
negative there.
And if we go to the
minimum point there,
the slope flattens out.
And so, of course, the
derivative there would be 0.
And then as we pass that
point, what happens?
Well, here, the slope is
increasing a little bit more.
Now the slope is
actually positive.
So the slope was negative, less
negative, 0, a little positive.
And then when you go here,
it goes more positive.
So let's see if we
can graph that.
Just to get an intuition.
Obviously I haven't written any
numbers down, so we don't know
what the exact value
of the slope is.
So what does the
slope look like?
So here it's really negative.
So the slope is going to be
something really negative here.
I'm just picking
a random point.
And then, at this point right
here, it was less negative.
So the slope is going
to be less negative.
And then here, roughly
here, the slope is at 0.
Right?
The slope was 0.
And then the slope gets a
little bit more positive.
And then over there, it gets
a little bit more positive.
So the slope, if we were to
actually graph the derivative
of the function at that point,
it would be an upward sloping.
And so I'm assuming this is
a second degree polynomial.
If this was third degree, then
this would actually be a curve.
So the slope will actually
look something like this.
And does that make sense?
Well, sure.
The graph of this could be
y is equal to, I don't
know, ax squared plus b.
And then the derivative, or,
you know, f of x is equal
to ax squared plus b.
And so the derivative of
that, of course, would
be-- what is that?
2ax plus 0.
So this would just be a line.
And it actually
goes through 0, 0.
But it didn't have to.
But hopefully that gives
you a little intuition.
But now let's move to
the second derivative.
So the slope of the slope.
Let me draw it down here.
The second derivative.
My wife is coming home, so I
have to finish these videos
before she gets here, otherwise
I have to continue it tomorrow.
She called 5 minutes ago,
so I have to hurry.
Anyway, so this is f
prime, prime of x.
Or the second derivative.
So what's happening to the
second derivative here?
Well, the second derivative
is just the slope
of the derivative.
So what's the slope?
Well, it's just a constant,
in this case, it's just a
constant upward moving slope.
So the second derivative--
actually, if we were to just
evaluate that-- it would be 2a.
So it's going to look
something like this.
And I can actually-- it's going
to look-- it's just going to be
a constant number, and it's
going to be positive.
So, in general, when you study
your extrema points, and say,
whether it's a minimum or a
maximum, et cetera, et cetera.
The way that you think about it
is, well, if it's a minimum
point-- like this-- if it's a
minimum point, what is
happening to the
slope around it?
Well, the slope has to be
constantly increasing, right?
Even though, for example.
Even though, as we go from
here to here, the value
of f of x is decreasing.
The rate at which it's
decreasing is getting less.
So the slope is
actually increasing.
It's getting less
and less negative.
And then it increases
even more.
So you know you're at a
minimum point when the
slope is increasing.
And similarly, you know that
it's concave upwards when the
second derivative is positive.
So hopefully that helps you a
little bit, getting the
intuition of what happens when
you're at a minimum point and
you're concave upwards.
Well, what happens when
you have the opposite?
Well, pretty much everything
becomes the opposite.
Let's say that this
is your curve.
I know that this is the x-axis.
If that's your curve,
well, here you have
a very high slope.
Then your slope becomes a
little bit less, then it
becomes 0, then it becomes a
little bit more negative, then
it becomes more negative.
Then it goes more negative.
The rate of the slope becomes
more and more negative the
whole time that we're kind of
going through this
maximum point, or this
concave downward.
So what will the
slope look like?
Well, in this example, if I
were to draw the derivative,
the slope is going to
look something like this.
Because back here, the slope
is-- actually, a really high
number is going to be up here.
And then as we get close-- as
we move further and further,
increasing values of x--
the slope decreases.
It becomes 0 right around here.
And then it just
keeps decreasing.
And then similarly, if we were
to draw the second derivative,
what will that look like?
Well, the second derivative
is just going to be the
slope of this function.
So it's just going to be a
negative number, if we assume
that this is constant.
So the second-- if this is
the x-axis, the second
derivative is going to
be something like that.
It's going to be some
negative number.
I'm assuming this is 0, 0.
Anyway, I'm about to run out
of-- well, I'm not about to
run out of time, but I think
I don't want to rush it.
So, that's the maximum,
minimum points.
And in the next video, I'll
give you a little intuition
on what happens with
inflection points.
And then we will do a bunch of
examples that you will normally
see in a calculus textbook.
But I just wanted to do this
for you because there's nothing
magical about a lot of the
rules that you'll learn.
You know, when they say, oh,
you take the second derivative.
And if the second derivative is
positive, it's concave upwards.
And if the second derivative
is negative, it's
concave downwards.
And you might, you know,
fill your brain with all
of these memorizations.
But it's hopefully-- if
you think about it this
way-- fairly intuitive.
And hopefully, it should be
fairly intuitive that whenever
the first derivative
is 0, your slope is 0.
And you're at a point
that is interesting, at
least in this context.
But anyway, I will do the next
video on inflection points, and
then I'll do a bunch
of actual problems.
See you soon.